[Music]
aaron
is with us in kentucky hi erin how are
you
i'm doing great how about yourself
better than i deserve how can we help
well um i my question is
my wife and i and we have about 15 000
in debt and we're wanting to go through
um
the financial peace university thing and
hopefully get out of that really quickly
but then after that
um i'm really interested in being able
to
invest and prepare for our future but i
only have about a 30 000
a year job and i just didn't know if
that was enough to be able to become
the everyday millionaire or if i need to
look into
growing my income significantly or just
kind of what's your fault or on all that
oh buddy you are speaking my love
language through here
you know inside of that and in that
national study we did when we talked
over 10 000
it was never about the income being the
barrier it was about having a plan for
your money
so what is it what line of work are you
in my friend
currently uh i am a i deliver male
uh so i i work at the post office but i
don't work
necessarily for them it's a outside
contractor uh company
okay and they buy the routes and then
you know i deliver
how old are you i'm 26.
okay so what do you want to be doing
when you're 46 same thing
um i mean depends on what you know what
it just depends i mean i'm okay with it
i i enjoy what i do
um i have i'm also involved in ministry
i've got some other i have a photography
business i'd love to see that grow
and honestly would love to build just to
work for myself but
i don't know if that'll ever truly take
place or not
um well here's the thing that's right
okay i don't mind you
there's no shame at starting at any
income
and uh obviously if you save
steadily a goodly portion of your income
eventually you will become a millionaire
at virtually any income
in order to save that you've got to be
able to eat while you're doing that
and so uh you know logic tells all of us
that the more money you make
the more you could save and therefore
the faster you would get them
and so what i would challenge you on is
not so much to say
oh you don't make enough money to win
instead i would just say
uh if i'm you i want a life plan that
includes personal growth
and as you grow personally and you
should do
something in the marketplace that pays
you more because you should be worth
more
and so an example of that would be to
open your photography business on the
side
and you know get better and better at it
get better at photography get better at
business get better at marketing
get better better at social media until
your photography business grows and
i mean it doesn't have to but it
wouldn't make me mad if you made two
hundred thousand dollars a year doing
that it wouldn't make you mad either
so but but that's a growth plan for you
that the money reflects
instead of saying no people that make
thirty thousand dollars just can't do it
right because your life is never a
snapshot it's a film strip
that's a very good point dave and your
income's gonna grow and here's the
beauty of it it should grow
you get out of debt now you don't have
any hands reaching into your wallet
you get a chance to have the money
actually hang around with you
and go to an investment account or go
toward giving
you get a chance to be in control so get
yourself out of debt
build up an emergency fund then start to
invest
david khan sounds like a broken record